have you noticed
like people switching up around you the
bigger you're getting
people coming out the woodworks people
hitting you for money you know what i'm
saying
that [ __ ] be daily bro like i ain't
gonna say no names but i go through that
[ __ ]
daily bro like and it's getting to the
point i'd be like damn i wish i would
know became a rapper like damn i wish i
what if i wasn't successful you wouldn't
be calling me you wouldn't be trying to
be for me made this song about me when
you could call my phone
you know what i'm saying like [ __ ] it's
like people i never thought would switch
on me just change
every day and that's it how you just
thank him bro does that [ __ ] happen with
like rappers in your city where you
thought you were cool with someone but
it might be a good look for them to try
to say some [ __ ] about you because it
helps kind of boost their [ __ ]
man that's man y'all notice it this is
going on bro
all right [ __ ] you you think you love
for like
it ain't that for real like once you get
to a certain level in life [ __ ]
looking at you like damn
you poor to do syz but where you was
when i was like
po and where you was why you ain't with
me right now when i offer this [ __ ] like
come with me hit the road with me you
know what i'm saying
you ain't got to pay for [ __ ] right now
i'm saying hit the road me grind it out
with me you want to be a rapper too come
on come around with me do what i did you
know what i'm saying
cause i ain't nobody i ain't never had
no og and no other person saying humble
little
take this bag of money uh go do that you
know what i'm saying i did it myself bro
work ethic man i'm saying i had to cry
for this [ __ ] so i feel like if you want
that [ __ ] you got to cry for that [ __ ]
too
yeah man told me you want that [ __ ] no
is that that work ethic is missing man
with a lot of these kids bro who you
telling
and uh i feel like that's kind of what
separates
the good from the greats is that is that
work ethic that willingness to eat [ __ ]
for
the beginning of your career and go stay
in the super eight motel in whatever
random city you might go grab a little
bag at you know what i'm saying and
i come back to sacrifice you got to
sacrifice [ __ ] bro
you know what i'm saying sacrifice
anything that's worth
worth having you got to sacrifice got it
bro and i swear once you sacrifice
that [ __ ] it's gonna work out bro i
promise bro
like that [ __ ] be god telling you to do
the [ __ ] you supposed to go through this
[ __ ] but it's just like a test like if
you don't you're gonna be stuck in the
same
it's common sense bro if you don't do it
you're gonna be stuck in the same spot
if you do you're to elevate it no i'm
saying you got to go get it you can't
sit on your ass off yeah man
like what what what's kind of the
biggest sacrifice you think you've made
um to kind of get where you are
when i first moved to atlanta like my
favorite when i had the apartment though
not the house when i had the apartment
when i said when i was in jacksonville i
went down like damn
all this [ __ ] going on around me this
and that all these labels calling
[ __ ] dying every [ __ ] other day and
[ __ ]
i didn't need to get away from this [ __ ]
i need to be in a better environment for
me to record
link up with new artists and [ __ ] so i'm
like [ __ ] this [ __ ]
i need an apartment in london i went to
london that's how that shot
yeah i think um i mean [ __ ] is paying
off for you
i mean you say the deluxe is coming
mm-hmm and
you already got another mixtape coming
as well two minute states
so you're gonna flood the rest of the
year yeah i'm from the flood i don't
wanna just show them like i'm not just
no like
this rapper obviously people know i'm
not that's the song i brought right now
that's what's blowing me up right now in
the industry like that's what just got
my foot in the door
a dis on the [ __ ] you understand
that should be crazy